One of the Kennedy's genius boys came up
with the cars,
Kennedy's administration was run by a
lot of Harvard graduates and Ivy League
graduates,
and so,
you know,
they were supposed to be pretty
intelligent,
but intelligence and wisdom are not the
same thing,
but anyways,
um,
they established a policy which was
called mutual assured destruction,
which means if you hit me,
I kill you and then you kill me.
And so it'd be better if we just didn't
bother.
And the acronym was mad,
right?
Mutual assured destruction.
It's like,
you know,
just thinking about that it,
it's a chilling thought.
It's like what horrible entity thought
that up as a joke.
You know,
when you think,
well,
does that sum.
It says that some politicians,
ib of width,
like where'd that come from?
So that's a hell of a thing to make a
joke about,
you know,
mad.
Well that was right.
It was definitely mad,
you know.
And the,
the,
the odd thing is,
is that we didn't blow ourselves up and
we didn't have a third World War.
And you know,
you,
you can't make a solid claim that the
invention of nuclear weapons was
necessarily the worst thing that could
have happened,
you know,
because even the Soviets who were
completely insane,
and of course the model was to probably
even worse,
they weren't insane enough to start a
nuclear war.
Now style it,
there's evidence,
there is debate about it,
but there was an.
There's evidence that Stalin was
basically murdered partly by cruise
ship,
was who was his,
who was his successor when Stalin died,
Khrushchev and three other people were
in his house and what happened in
Stalin's house the night he died is not
clear,
but I read a book recently called
stolen.
Interestingly enough,
that was written by a guy who had access
to the full communist party archives,
which was relatively new thing.
And that was his conclusion.
And he also believed that Stalin was
gearing up to do it,
an invasion of Europe and that he didn't
give a damn how many cities would have
to be bombed in order for the Soviets to
rule through.
And Stalin.
He was like that,
you know,
Stalin was perfectly capable of taking
entire nations of people out in eastern
Europe by train and shipping them out to
Siberia in the middle of the winter with
nothing to eat and no tools and letting
them live,
which of course they didn't.
And that meant women,
children,
men,
you know,
shorn of all their belongings and thrust
out into the middle of nowhere to perish
or,
or live as they saw fit and if they
perished so much,
the better as far as Stalin was
concerned.
And so he wasn't exactly the sort of
person,
the idea of a nuclear war would
necessarily stop.
And it's certainly possible that that's
what he was hoping for.
You know,
because when we look at people like
Stalin and Hitler,
we think,
well,
you know,
thereafter world domination,
and you think,
well in some sense that's kind of a
positive motivation,
right?
I mean,
not really,
but it's like if you have a corvette say
and someone steals it,
you can think,
well,
I know why they stole it.
They want to have the corvette.
You know,
it's,
it's an understandable motivation to
want power.
It's not necessarily an admirable one.
Sometimes power is a perfectly
reasonable thing to pursue,
but I don't have any idea why we ever
assume that those guys were after
victory.
Like you should never make the
presupposition that everyone is out to
when some people are out to lose and the
more people they can take with them,
the better.
You know.
And when Hitler died,
he committed suicide in a bunker way
down below Berlin.
West Berlin was on fire and Europe was
burning.
It's like,
as far as I can tell,
that was exactly what Hitler was after
right from the beginning.
You know,
he was interested in fire as a purifying
agent.
You know,
he's a fire worship or in some sense
because if you look at the Nuremberg
gatherings of the Nazis,
you know,
they're spectacular,
spectacular celebrations,
unbelievably dramatic and impressive.
And they frequently featured fire and
fire's up purifying agent know,
and Hitler,
by the end of World War Two was he was
pretty contemptuous of the Germans
because they really hadn't served him
well.
That it wasn't like he thought,
well maybe it wasn't such a good idea to
start a whole second world war,
you know,
because he was a little on the
narcissistic side we might say,
but by the time the Russians came
marching in Germany was in ruins.
Hitler was perfectly happy to have the
allies tromp all over the citizens
because that's what they deserved
anyways.
And so that's the sort of guy he was.
And so why we would assume that he
wanted to win just because that's what
he said is something I'd never been able
to understand.
You know,
the kids who shot up columbine didn't
want to win.
I wanted to kill as many people as
possible to make a point and then they
wanted to kill themselves just in case
you didn't exactly get the point.
And the point was the more destruction
the battery and if I have to go along
with it,
hey,
no problem.
That just makes me a little bit more
serious than I might've otherwise be.
And so those sorts of motivations are
not pleasant to understand,
but we have enough documentation about
events like that,
you know,
especially the mass killings.
Those guys have written down exactly why
they do it.
Now.
I have some excellent books on
extraordinary vengeful,
a map serial killers that mass murders.
I know exactly how they think.
There's a great book if you're
interested in this sort of thing called
pans,
Ram p a n Zed r a,
m and Carl Pants.
Ram was a serial killer and rapist who
lived pretty much early in the 20th
century.
And he was a tough delinquency sorta kid
from a large family.
And when he was,
you know,
13,
14,
they sent them off to some reform school
and it was really run by the same sort
of people that run Canada's residential
schools and you know,
so those were basically predators on
children.
And of course he was raped and,
and,
and brutalized and tormented and in all
sorts of horrible ways.
And,
but he was a tough guy.
And when he came out he decided that,
you know,
the human race really wasn't worth that
much.
And that he was going to reek as much
mayhem as he possibly could for the rest
of his life.
He raped a thousand men.
He killed dozens of people.
He kept track of the dollar value of the
buildings.
He burned down like this was a serious
guy and he wasn't.
He was bent on destruction and that's
that when he was.
What were his dying words?
First of all,
there was a committee,
I believe,
of women who intervened on behalf of him
because they were anti capital
punishment.
And he said to them,
if I remember correctly,
that he wished the human race had one
neck so that he could put his hands
around it and squeeze.
So you know,
that was his way of pointing out to the
people who didn't think that maybe
capital punishment was justified in his
case that maybe they weren't thinking
clearly.
And then to the hang man,
he said,
hurry up you who's your bastard?
I could kill 10 men in the time it takes
you to hang me.
So you know,
you don't get a statement like that from
someone who isn't thoroughly committed
to what he's doing.